okay welcome back
I have NCO with me I kind of [ __ ] up
two times but we're back here and I
don't remember what I saw but basically
we ran oh [ __ ]
what what let's just take a photo
nothing really
my you went past this door and we can't
pass it for those who don't know my is
our sister take the [ __ ] photo whoa
oh come at me bro let's take the photo
boom shacka lacka I'm stealing more
farts catchphrase it's gonna be pissed
let's do table shot let's do a double
one yes it was so good let's do another
double
yes table oh yeah I don't know what to
call it
yes it doesn't do that much though
the solute damage I don't understand
what is he doing always die
we're hope it's not too confusing I know
people sometimes complain when I don't
follow it but sorry sometimes when I
record synced up and like the microphone
is muted my penis is hard
what stuff like that I'm just saying I'm
just saying I'm just just a human being
anyway we are a little girl who can take
photos [ __ ] like take fruit of this I
should be able to think oh there we go
come some butterflies
so yeah I hope it's not too difficult to
follow I guess we gotta go back to where
we were earlier the song is awful
Miya Miya
my sister is such a [ __ ] I hate her just
leaves me first I did all the work with
a boss fight and ah okay so I I guess
follow the butterflies maybe I don't
know
I don't know maybe maybe yes maybe no
Heil
okay hey let's go this way it's really
creepy this game it's not really like
jump-scare okay the house dumb scared is
never mind but I don't know it's more
creepy but I don't know we'll see we'll
see I almost left almost like almost
like I'm a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
okay here's the butterflies
oh wait there's totally some way I can
take a picture here
where this way Oh
like this
a frozen man
so what like what do we get from doing
that I don't understand oh here's the
butterflies
what
why do we go
what's this
oh is it the war yeah that doesn't look
like a door to me but why do I know
who's this yeah yeah what are you still
doing here I don't know how are you I
don't know bill begins the ritual that
happens
what you are back yeah I'm sorry
yeah you went I had to get out
she's the ceremony masters how she's
going to do it go get her there's no
time to gather up with her literary
insiders look for Sunderland somewhere
in the village yeah
the ritual is about to start hurry you
already freaking told me you have to
don't tell me twice
Wow an [ __ ] he's an [ __ ] okay so
photo time ugly ugly ugly ugly IBEW
yes camera loves you all right we got it
we got it we got it
so if you cannot find a way to leave the
village come and find me I may be able
to help oh you can help me ha I'm not
the [ __ ] in prison yeah Shane so we
need to look for statues that looks like
the one I think I saw one earlier I'm
not sure and on the statues we'll find
something maybe more butterflies but if
I has a mass stomach
I'm gonna sing that every time I say
butterfly in this game because I get the
feeling I'm gonna say butterflies a lot
just saying I'm saying
I see butterflies butterflies in my
stomach
ah come on walk normally my I'm sorry
about the FPS drops sometimes I am not
sure it's probably cuz I owe it hears
Holy One okay what what my up ah [ __ ] it
let's look here I guess I don't really
know where to go hey oh here's a statue
so we take a photo of it
perfect beautiful than nothing can I
pick it up there's what does this film
can be equipped by a camera on the mitt
what I film I'm so happy
and Neffe huh it's totally over here and
I guess we gotta take photo of it
actually don't
maybe we just click it the guardian d
decided to visit between sanity
examination examination on the lower
portion of the search you wanna resolve
oh sweet I have one part of the key it
shapes like one of the stone statues but
it's only in the right half oh [ __ ] all
right it's my [ __ ]
yes the camera loves you another photo
yes beautiful yeah
come on oh yes you're gorgeous
ha - gorgeous alright let's keep going
later dude
I would assume maybe we should go back
down now let's continue is there
something here now
maybe here what do I know I hate the
cutscenes they're so freaky
what
Oh
what are they doing that yeah sure let's
follow them why not make sense right if
I saw freaking priest doing all like oh
yeah but wait that's not that I'm normal
wait maybe they don't do hyah bah what
am I talking about
anyway shiny object shiny object sure I
want to shine on you I think that's
something how they go I wait I can't
take a photo somewhere ugly ugly ugly
ugly ugly
oh it says up there too cool so it's
maybe it's this statute
yes no it's not the statue but it's the
meter oh it's this statue where did it
go
ugly ugly beautiful well this is not it
rickety Frank but it's totally giving me
something on the radar where is it what
is that
I found it uh your ugly shrine shadow
but what do we get from doing that I
don't understand let's see if we can go
in here we can that's a bad idea like I
would never go in here
oh man is pretty creepy should we really
go there
shine on you
spare the autumn upgrade the camera
equipment on your phone in the menu all
right sweet
Oh Oh
Oh what is this a torture thing what are
these is cards never mind
it's so creepy why am I going here I
want to shine on you
sacred water yeah I'll take that I love
this sound that it shows up when you
pick it up it's like it's like a
bitch-slap that was very realistic
wasn't it sure it was anyway that's here
uh-huh let's go here I really don't want
to go in here unless I how to this is so
creepy
where was it oh there was
my yo all right she can't go in there
well that's the problem
what about here
yes herbal medicine thank you very much
thank you very much
a cup of currants slap what what
okay let's go out of here usually things
happen when I leave the room it's kind
of annoying like or if I stayed here my
entire life
wouldn't it wouldn't be very good stay
there
right what but the priests went here
they should be here huh let's go back
then I guess
confused beautifies confused we need to
find my you are serious and a soul and a
[ __ ] she's a [ __ ] ah sorry
I would only assume whether we go back
but I'm still not sure if it's right it
would be annoying as hell if I have to
go back here but I think it's okay it's
okay Kay what uh
okay
why are they butterflies I actually miss
the butterflies
I need my butter 5d did we go and hide
slot crap
what about this one of course
so where do we go that's that's where
the I really don't know
I can't walk close to this one is
there's nothing there well stir
butterflies
what was over here again I forgot is it
that then
they're walking here no
confused
where's the bottle ass where's my sister
where's everyone seriously well freaking
village what's in here though let's go
here
guess we never been
we can't go inside oh we can't go inside
oh wait I already a creepy background
noises freaks me out
and over here it was done
it's all true oh wait
Compu beautifies
oh yeah now I remember I'm slow and see
if we can rescue him or something it's
lost of course
let's talk to him again just see what's
up
house Nang sucks like that uh yes
yeah yes is that you yes